Is it bad to eat butter if I'm supposed to be cancer-free?
Oh, cancer-free? I think that person meant dairy-free.
So if you're supposed to be dairy-free, and you are... can you eat butter?
I get this question a lot. The problem is that yes, butter is dairy,
and if dairy can be driving your cancer, then eating butter could be driving your cancer.
However, the butter of substitutes that are out there,
you know, can be worse for you.
So I would say that, you know, if a person supposed to be dairy-free,
can they eat a little bit of butter? Yes.
I would say you'd better off eating a little bit of butter
than eating the butter substitutes, margarine things that are out there.
The plant oil-based butters, quote-a-quote, that are out there are not good for you.
So, you know, there's other substitutes you can have coconut oil,
you could have avocado oil and olive oil, but sometimes you need...
you're putting butter on something is going to be more appropriate
than using those other things.
So, using a little bit of butter I would say is fine,
even if you're supposed to be dairy-free.
Remember, it's not a... it's a diet, it's not a religion.
We're not forming a cult about your eating here.
It's about taking a balanced approach,
and okay, if dairy's driving my cancer, I'm going to stay 95% dairy-free.
It doesn't mean you can't have some dairy.
You know, a food sensitivity here, that if you eat that thing,
you're going to cause inflammation.
Let's say if you have gluten, you know, your antibodies,
like the other question we had, they have glutinate antibodies,
and you eat... well, I'm just going to... I'm pretty much gluten-free.
Well, pretty much gluten-free is like being kind of pregnant.
You're still going to cause inflammation every time you eat gluten,
you know, three times a week, and if you have antibodies to,
you know, brain cells, neural antibodies,
you're going to cause inflammation of the brain in further destruction,
so you can't just kind of go halfway at a diet like that.
But when you're talking about what could be feeding cancer,
if you've removed most of those things that you're...
that you're consuming in what could be feeding cancer,
then you've... you know, having a little bit of it
isn't going to cause the cancer to take off and grow.
So, it's about having that balance.